[Music]
20-19 was one hell of a year for anime
as hit franchises like attack on titan
my hero academia and one punch man made
successful comebacks there were also
plenty of new shows like Vinland saga
and the promised neverland that won our
otaku hearts and left us wanting more
with a year almost over we look forward
to 2020 and January promises to be
blazing hot with a slew of manga and
light novel series getting their anime
adaptations and a few old favorites
returning to take their stories forward
it looks like it's gonna be a Happy New
Year we couldn't ask for more
so here are our picks for the top 10
most anticipated anime of winter 2020
[Applause]
coming in at number 10 a university
student takes a break from studying and
enters the fantasy world of the mega hit
video game infinite dendrogram the anime
is based on a fairly new japanese light
novel series that received a manga
adaptation in 2018 set in tokyo in 2045
infinite dendrograms taken over the
world as the most realistic VR game out
there one the promise is to make its
players experience the five senses as if
they're real this virtual worlds filled
with monsters demons powerful weapons
and other magical beings fans of the
novel say the virtual world within the
game feels incredibly real which in
their opinion sets are novel apart from
many others in the video game fantasy
genre will the anime managed to
successfully blur the lines between
fantasy and reality we recommend you
watch to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
now don't let the title mislead you this
one has nothing to do with the cute
furry friends we keep at home instead
it's about a group of psychic
individuals who enter the minds of
others and manipulate their memories
often to commit crimes and influence
decisions with criminal consequences the
wielders of disability are called pets
going simply by its trailer this anime
seems to be just the thing for fans of
the bizarre and the weird the
supernatural psychological genre is a
veritable gold mine of brilliantly
bizarre anime such as Psychopaths Death
Note a raised and parasite and is set to
air on Amazon Prime video this January
another manga anime adaptation coming to
us in the first month of 2020 is
plunderer which comes in at number 8 the
story set in alcea where numbers rule
the residents lives each person has a
count and this decides not just their
social status but also their existence
when the count drops to zero that's it
for the person a world of numbers is
fairly unexplored territory in anime and
manga which makes the central theme of
plunderer rather interesting the show
follows the journey of a young girl as
she sets out to fulfill her mother's
last wish aided by a handsome masked
hero the bright visual seemed to be in
vivid contrast with the animes dark
sounding title a first look at plunderer
promises a big dollop of fantasy
adventure action and even some romance
are you excited for this new show
the next entry on our list is the story
of a young human girl who finds a father
figure in a golem or guardian of the
forest Somali and the forest spirits
sent in a world ruled by spirits goblins
and strange creatures where humans are
persecuted and driven to near extinction
from the looks of it the animations
captured the visuals of an enchanted
world in outstanding fashion and a
heartwarming tale of a father-daughter
bond never fails to tug at the
heartstrings now does it did someone say
mushi she meets with Saki drop Somali
and the forest spirits also another
retelling of the classic anime theme of
humanity in decline explored ever so
brilliantly in attack on Titan but this
one promises to be utterly different by
taking a more slice-of-life approach
with its stunning visuals and cast of
fabulous creatures will this be one of
2020s big anime hits we'll find out soon
enough almost at the halfway mark now
and the next anime on our list is Madoka
Magica side story' macchia record that's
a mouthful isn't it share jawed for
january this is based on a 2017
smartphone game and serves as a spin-off
to Madoka Magica from 2011
margarit records expected to follow the
game's storyline it introduces a new
heroine
Iroha Tamaki a magical girl in search of
her missing sister the magical girl
sub-genre in anime is immensely popular
and the Madoka Magica franchise is no
exception the original anime spawned
numerous manga adaptations of video
games in a film series so I guess it's
only natural then that for fans of
magical girls who fight evil witches
with the help of their dolls the
anticipation of Margo Records sky-high
[Music]
from magical girls and witches we move
on to monsters demons and spirits coming
in at number five it's inspector
inspector tells the story of Kotoko away
Naga a 17 year old girl who communicates
with otherworldly creatures that don't
always play nice helping her in her
quest is University student career Ogawa
the anime is based on a supernatural
light novel that's also been turned into
a manga published by Kodansha comics for
English audiences can Kotoko help solve
the problems of the supernatural world
in her role as god of wisdom while also
keeping the peace between spirits and
humans and will she win the heart of
Kuro
whom she's fallen in love with her first
site inspector follows in the footsteps
of shows like Kamisama kiss and Kakori
Oh bed and breakfast for spirits though
with one marked difference unlike the
male protagonists in these other anime
who are all yokai or demons who rose
very much human mystery and monsters all
in one anime what's not to like about
that
[Music]
Darwin's games another online game genre
show that makes the cut at number four
on our list of anticipated winter 2020
anime in Darwin's game an ordinary high
schooler clicks on a strange mobile app
and gets sucked into a deadly game where
players wield supernatural powers
sounds familiar enough now doesn't it
accompanying him on this game of life or
death battles with no option to quit is
a veteran player who's blonde pigtails
and frilly red dress contradict her
fighting prowess the anime is based on a
survival battle manga series with the
same title will Darwin's game replicate
the success of other online game based
anime some fan forums are already
drawing parallels between its two main
leads and the sword art online sceeto
and asuna who may well be the most
famous couple of this genre while such a
comparison may be premature at this
moment a little hype never hurts does it
onto the top three now with season three
of a certain scientific railgun as we
start the countdown to the top what
makes this anime different from others
is that it's the first sequel on the
list season three of a certain
scientific railgun comes six years after
the second season fans of the series
will remember this tale of
supernaturally powered high school
students called Esper's who live in
Academy City a place that's said to be
at the forefront of scientific
development but where things aren't
always what they seem
the central character Mikoto Misaka can
manipulate electricity and is the
titular railgun like the earlier seasons
season 3 will also be produced by
j.c.staff the studio behind key animes
such as food Wars and Toradora as well
as a certain magical index and a certain
scientific accelerator from the same
franchise as a certain scientific
railgun missing the top spot but
delighting it spans nonetheless is the
anime adaptation of the 2000 manga Dora
hador oh this anime set in a
post-apocalyptic world called the whole
who's human residents live wretched
lives they're tortured killed and
experimented upon by magic users who
come from a different dimension
our hero chi minh is an amnesiac
dumpling loving human with a head of a
lizard the story chronicles his mission
to find the sorcerer whose experiment
resulted in his far from human
appearance fans of the manga have long
praised it for its gritty art style
well-thought-out characters and
fast-paced story
bouncing straight in at the number one
spot is the highly anticipated fourth
season of the smash hit volleyball anime
haikyuu this story of underdogs turned
giant killers is a fan favorite and not
just among admirers of sports anime
season 3 from three years ago set the
bar high with plenty of thrills and
character development despite the plot
being a single match stretched over ten
episodes there was never a dull moment
will season four live up to the hype as
Hinata and the boys from karasuno head
to Tokyo for the Nationals will the once
mighty Crows take flight again if you
want to know keep your game face on when
January rolls in so there you have it
the ten anime we're most excited about
as we usher in winter 2020 and you don't
have to wait too long as it's all
happening in January please leave a like
if this video was useful to you and
really appreciate it and subscribe to
the channel for more exciting anime news
and lists I'll see you next time on bin
eat you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]